you're sitting in traffic Wilshire
Boulevard I'm sure it was a lovely la
intersection with lots of commotion was
this your first feature script that you
were planning to write or had you
written prior feature script I had
written many feature scripts most of
them I had written right after I got out
of film school largely with an eye
towards trying to sell them or get them
set up to be produced sort of within the
studio system a few of which I even
liked I mean I some of them I'm glad I
wrote just because I think you need to
write a certain room bad scripts just to
get to a better script but yeah I had
been writing a lot and with the few
things that I had that had been
well-received I was still running up
against the roadblock of people saying
this this is a potentially a makeable
script but not with you as a director
you've never directed a feature no one's
gonna take that risk
and so really after we leave was my
answer to that recurring complaint I was
like fine if that's the case I'm just
gonna go make my own movie and get that
one excuse out of the way I will I will
be a feature film maker by making my own
film and then I can hopefully return to
trying to get something bigger budget
things off the ground
and these were producers that you were
pitching that were saying producers
agents you know just I think and never
by the way in a mean way you know I
think appreciative of the the sort of
work that I was trying to do and
interested in the stories I wanted to
tell but just being Frank about just the
reality of who they were going to
entrust X dollars with and that it would
be a hard fight for someone who hadn't
made a feature which of course is sort
of a catch-22 right you know like we
talked a lot about access to the
industry and if the access point is how
come you haven't already made something
we get caught in this vicious circle
right and so I just wanted to break out
of that and for me the solution was just
making a very small budgeted film that I
could direct and craft in the way I
wanted which again I did primarily just
as a form of self-expression you know I
made the movie not as a career calling
card primarily not as a strategic move
in Hollywood I made it because I just
wanted to tell that story I think the
benefit is it now makes me a director in
a lot more people's eyes
and it has open more doors but that
wasn't really my main reason for doing
it speaking of access I know this is
taking a little bit of a divert
assignment but what what are some of the
misconceptions whether they're from
students or just other people in the
industry about access and and what have
you seen from going through this process
being told this yourself that you can't
do it I think if we're specifically
talking about feature films I think the
biggest problem with access is just that
the business entirely has changed since
you know a lot of us fell in love with
movies there just are so many fewer
smaller movies being made by the
studio's and the big production
companies that I actually just think
opportunities for newer directors or
less experienced directors just aren't
even there I actually think that the a
lot of that access problem is just
they're not in the business of making
those movies that they used to give to a
younger director they're just making
these huge movies that being said I
definitely think for sure that the
overall industry has biases against and
their structural biases right their
biases that come not from necessarily
bad intentions but there are barriers to
women to people of color for sure the I
think the hope right is that there's an
antidote to that which is what we can
now make our own content and I do think
that that is a valid idea that the way
around the access problem is to make
stuff but I think the funny thing these
days is I don't know the model anymore
is make a low-budget films that you can
then jump up to a you know a lower mid
budget studio movie because those don't
even exist you know III think that
really I've sort of rethought how I
think about my career I'm just gonna
keep making movies like I actually don't
expect there to be this moment when all
of a sudden now I don't have to
self-produce or at least you know
partially self-produced my own movies
because I don't know that those that
that path is this anymore
I really think of making these films
like I want to make these movies and
I'll make them the career of directing
movies in Hollywood there's so few films
made these days think about it that I
don't know that that's a path that one
sort of incrementally gets to sometimes
you make it feel good enough on your own
that you get that lightning strike and
you can level up that big way
I don't think there's any more
incremental steps to those big movies
anymore I think there's nothing in
between so when your students come to
you with questions about you know access
are you just telling them that the same
thing basically just don't try to like
make something just so you can get to
that next level so that someone will
quote endorse you I mean the very first
thing that we talked about at oxy is
that the skills involved with filmmaking
and with media making we don't think of
those as skills that are exclusively for
Hollywood I think we live in a world
where the ability to tell your story and
express yourself visually is something
that everyone needs to do individuals
companies nonprofits governments
cultural institutions all of them need
to do that and so I think of this
toolbox artistically and logistically
that we're giving people in the
classroom as applying to a huge amount
of life when we talk specifically about
access to Hollywood I do tell people I
was like I don't think that independent
so I don't think that film director is a
career I think film director is an
aspiration I think independent film
director is a calling or I wish I had a
better word than hobby because I don't
think it's a hobby but I don't actually
think it's a career path I think it is
the thing one does is you're compelled
to do it but if you really if you were
to corner even when you think of a
successful independent directors and ask
them did you pay your mortgage which
filmmaking income this year so many of
them will say no and that's just a
reality and that's not a reason to stop
making movies it's a reason to ask
yourself why am i making movies if you
are making movies because you just feel
compelled to do it
that's the right answer
you